Organisms with supernatural powers are always
fascinating!
But they are no more
restricted to fiction stories.
They are a part of our practical scientific
world!
Yes!
Imagine a mice glowing in the dark, or a plant
that fights its deadliest predator!
These are not just thoughts, but successful
experiments!
Today, all thanks to
Biotechnology, we have several products with
wide applications in the fields of
agriculture, environment, healthcare and many
more.
And what kind of Products are we talking about?
Well, in this video, we will
mainly be discussing about the transgenic
organisms, also known as Genetically
Modified organisms, and abbreviated as GMOs.
And what do we mean by
transgenic or Genetically Modified Organisms?
Well, an organism which contains DNA from
another organism integrated into its
genomic DNA is called Transgenic organism.
So will transgenic organisms be
different from their original parental forms?
Of course yes!
A mice will not usually
glow in the dark, but when we manipulate it’s
genes, then the transgenic mice
obtained shows the unusual ability to glow
in the dark brightly!
Let us get introduced to these examples one
by one.
To begin with, we have the
cotton plant named “Bt cotton”
And what does this “BT” mean?
Does it stand for “Biotechnology”?
Nope!
The
prefix “BT” stands for “Bacillus thuringiensis”,
the bacteria which comes to the
rescue of Cotton plants!
Bt → Bacillus thuringiensis
Have you come across the phrase “The Enemy
of my enemy is my friend?”
Well, that is exactly the case we are going
to glance at!
Cotton plants have the biggest enemies in
the form of insects.
And there are
certain bacteria, like Bacillus thuringiensis,
which are like the enemies of these
insects.
They are actually capable of producing certain
toxins that can kill these
insects.
Thus, for the cotton plant, their “enemy’s
enemy”, which is the bacterium
is like a “friend”.
And this relation is exploited by genetic
engineers to get cotton
modified!
Let us find out how!
The first thing we need to know is about the
protein, and then, about the “gene”
which creates the magic!
These bacteria produce certain proteins, which
are capable of killing various
insects like cotton bollworms, beetles and
others.
These proteins are also called
toxins.
The genes encoding the toxins is called “cry”
gene.
And don’t these toxins
harm the bacterial cell?
Nope!
Inside the bacterial cells, these toxins are
present
in the form of crystals which are inactive
by nature.
The crystals get activated only
when in contact with apt pH conditions, found
in the gut of insects!
Crystals get activated → Apt pH conditions
Hence, the toxins are harmful only to the
insects and not the bacterial cells!
Now what we do is take the “cry” gene
from the bacterium and insert it into the
cotton plant through one of the various methods
of gene transfer.
And once
inside the cotton plant, the gene gives rise
to proteins, which are present in the
inactive crystalised forms in the plant as
well.
These when consumed by the
insects, get activated inside their gut, creating
holes in the lining and eventually
killing the organism.
This is how cotton plants get the ability
to naturally fight the threats and get
benefited.
In this way, transgenic plants can be created
using genetic engineering.
Various
other useful plants that have better resistance
capacity, or which have high yield,
can be designed using such techniques.
Several important and beneficial traits can
thus be incorporated in plants.
And what about animals?
Well, transgenic animals are also a boon to
researchers.
Let us learn about an interesting transgenic
animal in the next video!